I have to ask you a question
Josh grobin was a guest on your show and
he tweeted out a picture from his
dressing room at the crazy ones and oh
that's my dressing room
that's your dressing room why do you
that that's a doll I guess a life-size
Candice Bergen doll why is that in your
dressing room why do you have a
life-size Candice Bergen doll in your
dressing room
no no not everybody does yeah because I
found her in david Kelly's closet and I
thought she was really cool producer
David Kelly you found you were looking
through his stuff he wasn't there are
you watching David yeah I mean somebody
sent me into your office to get this is
not good I just had a son live
television oh it's not live don't worry
about it this was shot nine years in
advance
oh so apparently I guess on Boston Legal
William Shatner's character had a thing
for her character and wanted to have
relations over sex
yes translate thank you thank you and
she wouldn't so he had a doll made so
that he could you know have his way
thank you yeah and then I found it all
so you were looking through David
Kelly's office and you filled a
life-size Candice Bergen doll sex sex
doll well I mean David Kelly doesn't use
a sex doll but if it is is it a sex doll
what constitutes the like what's the
exact definition of it well it's a doll
you can put your penis in yeah
[Applause]
no plates I translate for you Andy
translation yes I do not put my penis no
does it have no it does not you told a
sex doll I brought in an expert we
questioned you yeah so it does not have
I didn't even think to check that now
I'm just gonna out all my friends Seth
Green was the one that checked it wasn't
me okay I'm just putting it out or I'm
sure Seth checked it right away
when you spend at the Bergen doll you
check for a vagina and it's done I think
everybody should have a Candace Bergen
ball it's awesome yeah well can you use
it for anything I would use it again to
just get in the carpool lane you're
driving in Los Angeles
like that's Conan O'Brien is with
Candice Bergen I have car seats for that
no I it to play play pranks on people on
set like I'll call south of it oh my god
Candice Bergen is on site today and she
really wants to meet you and come to my
trailer and he'll come in expecting to
see Candice and then he sees Candice oh
so you're Akili inviting people in and
they see that doll does anyone stay in
there for a suspiciously long time okay
leave it alone oh my god I just did a
joke a good family a little afterglow in
that picture yeah make sure Groban looks
pretty
and she's very happy too I just also
like the fact that you're not pointing
out the obvious that she is also holding
a pillow with my face on it which I did
not see when Josh put that picture out
there until later
I also apparently walk around with
pillows with my face on them well yeah
I've got things I liked you won in your
dressing room well thank you very much
thank you the pillow the pillow not the
doll I'm just saying the pillow I can
get the doll I said my mom's not
watching tonight oh she's gonna tune in
now